we're gonna find the right girls for
this where do we even go what we're
about to do something awesome you know
it really is hard to imagine Zac Efron
struggling to find a date but that's the
premise of his crazy new comedy Mike and
Dave the wedding dates it is kind of
like wedding crashers meets girls gone
wild so it really is no shocker that
things got a little out of hand when our
Carly Steele sat down with the cast this
film is hilarious tomorrow I got is that
girls are smarter than guys and more
hardcore I don't know guys do it I
didn't get that I didn't get that vibe
at all we've got your first look behind
the scenes of the comedy whose title
really does explain it all
Mike and Dave need wedding dates we
don't want you showing up stag and rye
on each other up looking for good girls
but Anna Kendrick and Aubrey Plaza's
hard-partying characters conned their
way in I got the most lip action so I
want to know who has the softer lips is
it Adam or is it Anna
oh all three of you guys have great lips
let's just leave it in back no no let's
be at the bottom of it let's not just
leave it okay you tripping
Dave I'll be honest with you I can't
continue where this horse what I did see
what the horses you are but double it's
like I've had opportunities dude that
was before and like they always bring in
a double with the worst but that's just
an easy trick to make you get your butt
out I think they're manipulating me yeah
yeah